and concurrent mark and sweep and move
them together and bit the best of all
worlds
and it was a great step in the right
direction however it still stops the
world
stops all the threads to do the copying
of objects
so all shenandoah is is that we're going
to copy the objects while your program
is running
that's it
okay so i know you guys all care about
n10 runtime
and so i need to be absolutely honest
and straightforward here
shenandoah is all about shorter pause
times there's no such thing as a free
lunch
it's going to impact the end to end run
time and i'm going to tell you about why
as i go along
so let me say what do you mean by ultra
low pause time okay so
shenandoah is not pauseless um it could
be pauseless we have plans to make it
pauseless
but for now the first step is just doing
concurrent evacuation
and i came up with these numbers i
pulled these numbers out of my head
um 10 millisecond pause times for 100
gigabyte plus heaps because that makes
people happy
that it's listening to numbers the
reality is if you have a thousand
threads and they all have really big
stacks
you're not going to hit the 10
millisecond pause time at least not in
the current
shenandoah maybe later on when we get to
the shenandoah 2.0
so why not pauseless it's harder
it's one thing to get your brain out of
moving objects out from under the
running java program
it's another thing about keeping the
graph consistent while only stopping one
thread at a time
and so we're taking one step at a time
um i'm going fast so if you want to
interrupt me with questions because i'm
going too fast please do because
i get nervous and i talk quickly um what
exactly is it that the gc is organizing
i wasn't sure of my audience for my talk
so bear with me um
in a java program or a lot of
object-oriented programs you have stack
frames
so here we have two stack frames for foo
and bar
and then they have immediate values like
42 and 6.847
but they also have references to objects
that are allocated in the heap
so arrays and objects and as you can see
some of these objects are referenced by
more than one stack
and some of these objects are referenced
by stack frames and by other objects
and some of these objects like the one
i'm pointing at my screen you can't see
it some of these objects
like the bottom right are not referenced
by anybody
so all the garbage collection is doing
is going through finding the objects
that are pointed to that you can get to
compacting them into an area of memory
so that you know you've got better cache
line behavior
and freeing up space for you to allocate
new objects
that's all gc is it's simple stuff
what the heck i can just get up here and
talk my slides would have been a big
help but
you know i need to be able to recover um
so what is the big trick
for doing concurrent garbage collection
it's a big trick
is to move the objects while the program
is running and what's the trick for that
you need the compiler and the runtime
system to agree on where an object lives
so you can do that in one of two ways
you can take the way that another
company has done where they memory
protect the pages
and then whenever you hit one of those
pages
you take a trap and you copy everything
to two space and you keep going
or you can take the strategy that we
took we're back
thank you so much i really am competent
with computers i promise
i'm just nervous
all right we're going to have to go fast
all right so the reason concurrent
compaction is hard
is because you have references from your
stack frames and from your heap to point
to this object
and everyone has to agree at the same
time where that object lives
and so you can do that via memory
protection where you stop
you go through your memories your your
remembered set and you fix all those
things up
or you can do what we did which i'll get
to in a minute
so let's talk a little bit about what gc
does
it walks the stack it traces the live
objects and it copies objects
so all of the current gcs
do the tracing of the live object
concurrently while your program is
running
what we do is we do the tracing of the
live objects and the copying i'm going
to have to speed up a little bit
shenandoah 2.0 is the one that's going
to stop the
and walk the stack frames while the
program is running
so what do we do to make the pause time
shorter we only collect part of the heap
at one time there's no point to touch
lung lift data that isn't changing
we use multiple processors to gc faster
both for concurrent working and
concurrent evacuation
and we do gc work while the program is
running
so what does shannon do do to divide we
divide the heap into regions
we run a concurrent mark step over your
heap so that we know where all the live
objects are
this is both so we know which regions we
want to garbage collect we can pick the
pretty regions that have very little
live data
we can also know which objects are live
and need to be evacuated
when it's time to copy them
it is a copy and collector so i meant by
concurrent evacuation we copy while the
program's running
so here you can see that you know we
picked the two regions
that were the most garbagey and
we copied them over to a two region and
freed those regions up
so just to show you what i'm going to
use for the rest of the talk now that i
have slides
um we pick a collection set like those
two regions that were garbagey
and we compress them into one other
region and then when we're done
these two blue regions are the free
regions that are left after we've done
that so the targeted regions are red
the two regions are green and
there you go so what's our trick our
trick is
well i can i have two jokes here but
since they're falling flat i'm just
gonna tell you they're forwarding
pointers
um the first trick you know my first
joke was that we stole something from
1984 right we took the brooks forwarding
pointers
and and we revamped them to work in in
today's systems uh my other joke is that
we added a level of interaction which is
how you solve any hard problem in
computer science
so all of your accesses go through a
forwarding pointer
to find the relocation of the object now
i know everybody's sitting there and
they've got two things that they're
afraid of one is
oh my gosh that's a space overhead and
oh my gosh that's a time overhead
so depending on the size of your objects
it can be a space overhead
right if your program is all forward
long objects
then it's a 25 space overhead but i
don't think the programs we're looking
at are not
all small objects in terms of time
overhead
i'm not going to tell you what where we
are now but i will tell you there are
people i will tell you why we aren't
where we want to be
in a few minutes but there are papers
out there that show that an
unconditional read barrier can only cost
you approximately five percent
in terms of throughput so
just to be absolutely clear about how
this works your food pointer points to a
which is in a from region
the garbage collector comes along it
copies a
installs the forwarding pointer and
whenever anybody comes through foo to
access a they actually go through the
indirection pointer before they
they can read if they read the final
object
so one of the added benefits to this
technique
is that we no longer have remembered
sets and the generational
collector you have a card table
remembered set and that can be a
concurrency bottleneck because people
are writing to the card table
from disparity areas of the heap in g1
the remembered sets can get big in
original g1
they were a real problem in generational
g1 that got better and i'll talk about
that too as we go along
but the idea here is that we no longer
have remembrances we're no longer hiding
it right you know you have the overhead
of this one word for object
all right so here is a nice picture of
what shenandoah actually does let me see
if i can get over there given how well
i'm doing on my trip
um so your java threads are running
you've got all this concurrency life is
good
we're going to stop the world to do an
init mark what that means is we're going
to trace the roots
and find out what the roots point to so
we know where to start
we're going to start the java threads up
again and we're going to do our
concurrent mark while your threads are
running
we're going to stop again and do a final
mark to make sure that we've got the
correct graph
we're also going to do the evacuation of
the things the roots point to there
and then we're going to start your java
threads up again and we're going to do a
concurrent evacuation
now one thing that the astute observer
might notice is that
i haven't actually talked about where it
is that we clean up references
you have references to the heap that
point into from space
and that's actually a point of
contention between roman and myself that
we've been working on it if you have
plenty of space and all you care about
is pause times
you can wait until the next initial mark
and when you go through there you can
clean up all the references
if you're willing to take another short
pause you can start another concurrent
phase that cleans up all the references
so concurrent marking uses a technique
called snapshot at the beginning
anything that was live at the start of
concurrent marking is still considered
live
anything that was allocated since the
start of concurrent marking is
considered live
so we use this to update references in
my world
you can do either way it's command line
option you can keep track of the amount
of live data for each region and you can
tell which objects are live and need to
be evacuated
now one of the tricks about satb to get
it to work right
is that you need to keep your copy of
your graph consistent
so in this case i have x pointing to y
sometimes during marking
an object that's already been marked
will get written with y
and then x will get rewritten with w if
we didn't have some sort of a write
barrier in place
we would miss y and y would not get
marked so that's the first part of our
right barrier is making sure that y gets
marked
so how do we move an object while the
program is running it's basically the
same thing we did for parallel youngjin
except instead of just competing with
other threads we're now competing
with the java threads as well so we read
the forwarding pointer we allocate a
temporary copy over into space
we speculative cop speculatively copy
the data over
and we cast the forwarding pointer to
the new copy if we succeeded
we carry on if we failed we roll back
the thing we allocated in our
red local allocation buffer so we can
just go back
and we keep going
so reads we we allow you to read
in the from region this is one of the
things that i think is a benefit of
shenandoah over
the protected memory barrier version if
you have a protected memory barrier then
all reads have to generate evacuations
so when you get to a flip
you can have a read storm where
everybody's trying very hard to copy
stuff over
and your java threads aren't making
progress in our case
we don't have to copy on reads so your
java program that's going can keep doing
reads in fact
we can be even a little bit more clever
in that if you're reading the size of an
array
we don't even put an array barrier if
you're reading a final field
we don't put in a read barrier if your
final fields are getting changed under
the covers by asm that's your own fault
not my problem
good you know let's let's let's do what
the language intended
um writing triggers a right barrier and
our right barriers are more complicated
right the right barriers for satb like i
just described
are only triggered when you're writing a
reference our right barriers have to be
triggered whether you're writing an int
or a reference or anything and we're
doing the satb barriers
but we're also doing a copy on right
and the reason for that is if we allowed
you to write into from space
while the garbage collector was copying
objects there's the potential for those
rights to get lost
so we forced the java thread to copy the
object and then keep going and it can do
its rights in the two space and then any
thread that later comes along
can see that there is a race window
between a reader
and a writer but that's a race window
that would be there anyway so
the invariant is you're never allowed to
write into from regions
um the other bit of knowledge that we
came across is you have to write
two space copies so you can't write a
pointer to the from space
into the two space um it's a little if
you're familiar with garbage collection
research it's a little weird because
we're doing
snapshot of the beginning for concurrent
marking we're doing incremental update
for our evacuation but it's it's it's
what works for us now
and if i hadn't said it before let me
say it now this is a project in
development
um this is not a product i mean you can
download it you can play with it you can
contribute
but it's not really ready for your prime
time production system yet
um okay one of the things that i wasn't
anticipating
and that baker didn't anticipate in his
paper is what happens when you cast
right kaz is is complicated complicated
because you're comparing and swapping
you have a that has an object reference
x you want to move it from foo to bar
well
you can lose if foo hasn't been copied
yet
so one of the things that's a downside
to shenandoah that
is a problem that we need to address
maybe or maybe it won't be a problem
because uncontended causes are cheap
it's in order to do a cash you have to
copy all of your objects to two space
before you try and do the cash
so what would be a one a one cash
instruction
has the potential of all three objects
are in a targeted region for evacuation
if you remember i slide back before
that's not all of them that's only some
of them but if it is a targeted region
then we have the
the kaz is to move the object to two
space and then the cavs
this is just showing the copying of the
objects
um so does this mean that a right
could keep a java thread from making
progress for an unbounded amount of time
no i mean at the worst cases the cavs
where you have to copy three objects
and objects are limited in size to a
heap region which is settable on the
command line how big it is
objects larger than the heap region are
what we call humongous and are treated
separately and they never get copied
we use multiple threads we use what we
learned when we did parallel
garbage collection with work stealing so
as many processors as you have left over
that you aren't using
we can use to get the garbage collection
done faster and this is just a
demonstration of work stealing where
when you have an
undisciplined graph like you do in an
object graph
it works very well for work stealing you
compete to claim the roots
and then as you're tracing them you do
one child and you put the other child
children on a list for later
and you can quickly see here that that
all these other threads got in to
compete and are all helping
to do whatever this is whether it's
concurrent marking or
parallel evacuation well actually the
the concurrent evacuation doesn't use
quite the same thing but it is all done
in parallel
so the cost space it's an extra word
project
it can be expensive if you have a lot of
small objects it is the case that
words in the jvm are double word aligned
so we're hoping that
eventually down the line when we're
doing real performance tuning
there might be cases where we can save
that extra word by just sticking it in
an unused word in an object
time we have read barriers no other
garbage collectors
on the jvm have a read barrier in open
jdk as it is now
um and our right barriers are more
complicated this is why i'm saying
you're going to lose
some percent of time in throughput
however if what you really need is ultra
low pause times if having your
application go away
during a stock trading window or if you
have to meet a quality of service
uh deadline or you want an interactive
application and you can't afford
a one minute pause time maybe you're
willing to pay
ten percent or five percent to get
shenandoah running
so as i said our read barriers are
unconditional our right barriers we need
the satp right barrier
and we also need right barrier on all
rights even the rights of
integers and such oh
so what's our current status we have
something working
you can go and download it you can run
it we can pass small tests like spec jbm
and spec jb
we have passed the smoke test for some
applications like eclipse and thermostat
we're working on performance tuning
right now we have radar
gun and elasticsearch but i'm putting
out a call to all of you
if you have an open source application
that you think would benefit
from a low or no pause garbage collector
share it with me we'll test on it we'll
make sure it works
we'll do performance tuning on it so you
get something back out of it too
um we'd love to have that
so performance tuning let me talk a
little bit about that um
one of the things that that is kind of
an open research issue for us
is what the heuristic should be when do
you start a concurrent marking how large
should the collection set be
how many bites do you allocate before
you do this how many you know how full
does the heap region have to be to
qualify for the collection set
we think that's going to make a big
difference once we get it right we've
thrown some darts at dartboards to do
our best shot
now i know you guys are going to want
preliminary results and i'm really not
in a position to give them
but i'm going to give you a little bit
of of what i can
inspect jvm the only app the only
one that actually does significant
garbage collection work
is spec jvm compiler it's not our target
application it doesn't have 100 gigabyte
heap
we're just starting performance tuning i
thought we'd be further along when i
volunteered to do this talk
um but i can show you that we have
initial mark times
in five to eight milliseconds for
initial mark and final mark
our max times are 10 to 15 milliseconds
which isn't where we want but it's good
if you compare these to g1 with 31
milliseconds and 75 milliseconds
it's looking a lot better um i had to
include the references because to be
honest all we did was we took
the work of baker and the work of g1
and we put it together and we're making
it work
uh future work i love this section i can
say all the things that i wish i could
do
um we're gonna finish bainic application
testing and we're working really hard on
that we've got
radar gone working um we're working on
getting lucine and elasticsearch working
there's still some issues
um where our performance bugaboo is okay
two times true confessions time um when
we went to put the reed barriers into c2
i don't know if any of you have ever
looked at c2 and the jvm
it's an optimizing compiler that only
the very brave fear to tread in
so we put our reed barriers in at parce
time
because it was the easiest time to
figure out where they go unfortunately
what we didn't foresee
was that a bunch of compiler
optimizations don't get triggered
because they don't match
what they were expecting to see in the
nodes
so we have seen things like loop
optimization elimination not happening
sorry loop bounce checking elimination
not happening
so our goal is to take the read barriers
out of parsing
and to put them in right before code
generation and we think that's going to
get us
a lot of the performance back and when i
say performance right we want to be
within 10
we're actually at a factor of two the
absolute worst i saw was a factor of
eight once but that was
an anomaly i think that once we get c2
generating as good a code for shenandoah
as it does
for code without read barriers with
minor
adding the read barriers i think we
should be within the five percent that's
what
studies have shown that a read barrier
will cost
heuristics tuning like i talked about
one of the things that i really want to
explore
is whether or not the generational
hypothesis
in on its own makes sense
if you're familiar with generational
garbage collection there are people that
say that the benefit to generational
garbage collection
is not that your objects die young but
that your remembered sets are smaller
because it's very frequent that you have
new objects that point to old objects
but you rarely have old objects that
point into new objects
so the remembered set to be able to
collect the young generation
individually
is smaller than if you had any other
remembered set like in g1
um so my hypothesis is that we don't
need to be generational because we don't
have a remembered set
but we aren't in we aren't really there
yet we haven't gotten to the point to
test that
um and maybe we want to be generational
maybe we want to even have a remembered
set maybe we want to add an eden
i i like i said this is a project in
progress it's not done
um we definitely want to get to round
robin thread stopping we want to be able
to say we're really pauseless
and one of the other things that's on
our list to maybe look at
is g1 or shenandoah
lend itself really well to pneuma
awareness
and particularly working for red hat
where i have you know the colonel guys
sitting next to me
i have access to the folks that know how
that stuff works and we can probably get
something going
where we could have a pneuma aware
garbage collector not just in
the allocation area which other people
have done but also as
as your threads move around the data can
follow them
if you need more information or if you
want to download the code
you can download it from this url
i have a blog it's a little out to date
roman has a blog too his is better
or you can send us email and i'm hoping
that somebody has questions because i
rushed through this so
does anybody have any questions
thank you if you could
please stand up and ask your
okay maybe i should have talked about
save points um at save points in the
compiler
you are okay the question is that
compilers do nasty things
like key pointers into the middle of
arrays and such
and do we need to go through on every
read to make sure that we go through the
porting pointer
and the answer is we don't um when you
are at a safe point as long as you only
have to do it
potentially once per save point but
really if you read the java memory model
and if i want to hide behind it you
don't even have to do it then you only
have to do it after
any uh
any vol any instruction that would that
would cause a sink a memory sync
and in those positions in those cases
then you have to go and redo all your
read barriers
there any other questions yes yeah
we are working in the java 8 code base
so if you download shenandoah you get
java 8.
we have a jet in place and i'm going out
to java one in two weeks and hopefully i
will figure out how
we go about you know seeing if we can
get this put back upstream into oracle i
don't know how that works
and i mean having worked for oracle i
don't know how it works from the outside
and so we're trying to figure that out
to navigate that process and even if we
can i don't know if we can
yes
okay so if you have a generational
collector with a young gin and nolgen
what you have is you have a card table
and so every time you do a write
you put a little bit in the card table
that says hey guys when you do your
young generation collection i want you
to come and scan this card in the old
generation
because there's a reference there to the
young generation and if you move
something you have to update this piece
of the old generation
okay in g1 i can tell you how g1
originally did it
so back when i was working on g1 in the
dark ages
um we had a full remembered set and into
remembered set
so any any card anywhere in the system
that
it pointed into a particular region was
kept in a region remembered set
and since then they've made generational
g1 so that you don't have to keep
pointers from old t
to young because that's tindled by the
card table and they've also done some
remembered set coarsening and i'm not up
to speed on exactly what that is
um at least in g1 and in cms
they both have uh one is called a
current current refinement thread
and i don't remember what the other one
is but they both have a concurrent thing
that goes along
across the card table and figures out
what needs if they can do any cleaning
concurrently before you actually have to
start doing a stop the world pause the
opposite which is to increase the size
of an empty old generation my young
genji
just got larger um
the card scanning is really quick um and
i'm trying to remember exactly how it
does see we don't i haven't looked at
that in two years because i don't we
don't have a card
we don't have a card table yes you and
the tie-dye love tie-dyed
we are trying very very hard yes
we have we have put read barriers into
the interpreter we have
put read barriers into to the
the the server i mean the client
compiler and the client compiler you can
understand it's like a dragon book
compiler and you can figure out okay
this is what i need to do
when you run in a tiered compilation on
hotspot
there there's the you run interpreted
and once you hit a threshold you run
with the client compiler
which is sort of think of it as a fast
and dirty compiler
and when you've been running for a
longer amount of time you hit c2 which
is the optimizing compiler
which is i'm willing to take a little
more time to do this compilation
for code that's faster to execute and
that one is blackmagic
and that's the one that that our read
barriers tripped up
and that it's looking for particular
instructions sort of in an instruction
window
and because we added a read barrier
there it didn't recognize
it as what it's used to optimizing and
we honestly
i mean i have i've tried i really have
i've tried to penetrate c2 and it is
it's very tough and it seems like
our best course of action for our next
try is rather than doing in the parts
time now that we have them in parts time
and we've proven the theory that it all
works is to go back and put them right
up before machine generation
because we can see where that is we can
tag the nodes and we know these are the
nodes that we're going to have to have
barriers on
and well hopefully we can tag the nodes
into those
and where the c2 generates new nodes for
us we're going to have to figure that
out as we go along
and then put them at the end and
hopefully then
we'll have gotten all the compiler
optimizations in the middle and compiler
optimizations
will work for us yes
uh we we're hoping that we're based on
sound theory
the question was you know how do we have
confidence that this all works
um it's an awesome question and
we're we're based on good theory right i
think that you know
the idea is to publish a paper and make
sure that other people get to see it and
that other people agree that we're based
on a sound theory
we're doing a lot of testing we've
passed all of the tck
um which wasn't hard for a garbage
collector but the compiler folks were
impressed that we passed it the first
time
we are working for running big apps that
run for long periods of time
we also have something we stole uh
the memory protection trick and we use
that for verification
so we verify that you never write to
from space
we have other kinds of verification like
that
um we're doing the best we can to prove
that it's correct
i'm pretty sure that none of the garbage
collectors in open jdk are perfect
but i think that i think that we can do
well i think that we can do
a pretty sound job yes
one of the problems
do you have any comments on like the
impact on the optimizing compiler like
are there certain optimizations no
longer valid
in shenandoah or can we see improvements
versus
if you can name a specific optimization
to me i will go and research it i
don't know of any optimizations that g1
invalidates
okay sure send me an email i would love
to start a dialogue
i am not a c i'm not a compiler expert
i'm not a c2 expert
i'm doing my best to try and work my way
through and make sure that this simple
little you know one line of code that i
want
the right barrier hooks are already
there the simple one line of code that i
want to make get executed on all reads
gets put in place
that's where i am okay are there any
other questions yes
um i don't know how to answer that all
of the work i've done in garbage
collection has been in either list
machines
or jvms with a shared memory model
distributed garbage collection
is harder i know that it's harder i know
that finding cycles is harder
i know that any kind of stop the world
phase in a distributed garbage collector
is
10 times more expensive than it is in a
shared memory model
but i've never done one
any more questions are we done
i guess we're done thank you so much for
listening to me